[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اثار اعلان المشير عبد الفتاح
السيسي ترشحه للرئاسه في مصر ردود فعل
متباينه فيما اعلن عن اختيار صهر السيسي
رئيسا جديدا ل وعن تعيين رئيس الاركان
وزيرا للدفاع نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي
نناقشه في محورين ما تاثير قرار السيسي
على توصيف ما جرى في الثالث من يوليو بعد
كل ما قيل عن عدم نيه العسكريين السيطره
على
الحكم وكيف سيؤثر ترشح السيسي على مسار
التحول الديمقراطي وعلى مستقبل مدنيه
الدوله
بزيه العسكري وعبر تلفزيون الدوله الرسمي
اعلن المشير عبد الفتاح السيسي قرار ترشحه
لرئاسه مصر سيترك زيه العسكري بعد عقود من
الخدمه كما اشار ولكن من اجل الدفاع عن
الوطن على حد تعبيره السؤال المطروح بعد
هذا اين شعار يسقط حكم العسكر الذي تردد
في مصر بعد ثوره يناير تبدو مواقف الشارع
والقوى السياسيه المصريه من الامر متباينه
ما بين مؤيد من اجل تحقيق الاستقرار ورافض
لاستمرار هيمنه العسكريين على الحكم في
مصر شو السيي
بعمل شو لا يهتفون للاعب كره قدم احرز
هدفا بل لوزير دفاع مستقيل قرر خلع بزته
العسكريه وكان ذلك كما قال لامر جلل من
حوالي 45 سنه
وانا
بتشرف بارتداء هذا الزي للدفاع عن الوطن
والنهارده انا بترك هذا الزي ايضا من اجل
الدفاع عن الوطن 45 عاما كان فيها الرجل
ابنا للمؤسسه العسكريه وتلك لها تقاليدها
الصارمه حتى بدا السيسي وهو يتحدث عن
ترشحه كم ينفذ امرا لا يفعله الا جندي
مخلص ومخلص على ما قاله منطوق خطابه وقد
تحدث عن مكافحه الارهاب والاقتصاد وما
سماها استعاده مصر لكنه لم يتطرق في خطابه
القصير الى ما يجعل الدوله مدنيه فلا حديث
الا مقتضبا عن الديمقراطيه والحريات
والحقوق الفرديه فتلك امور تدور في سياق
ما هو مدني فيما الرجل ما زال ببزه
العسكريه في تسريبات صوتيه كان قد اعترف
انه يتحرر بالاحلام فلقد حلم ذات مره بسيف
وبساع اوميجا وبحديث يدور بينه وبين
الرئيس السابق السادات يقول فيه السيسي
انه ايضا سيصير رئيسا لمصر منام
اخر انا مع السادات بكلمه فبيقول لي انا
كنت عارف ان انا حب رئيس الجمهوريه قلت له
و اناا عارف ان حب رئيس الجمهوريه لنعرف
التامر ما بين عالم العسكريه الصارم وعالم
الاحلام المنفلت بد السيسي وكانه خلق
لمهمه مقدسه ليكون جنديا سواء ببته
العسكريه ام بدونها ثم استمع لنداء اكمل
جميلك فاضطر لترتيب البيت العسكري فجاء
بصهره رئيسا للاركان ونقل رئيس اركانه
المخلص ليحل محله في منصب وزير الدفاع
امور قالت عنها جهات معارضه انها اسقطت
ورقه التوت الاخيره عن تحرك الجيش في
الثالث من يوليو لتؤكد انه كان انقلابا
مكتملا الاركان
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه من لندن مع الكاتب
الصحفي عبد الله حموده ومن اسطنبول محمد
جمال حشم القيادي في جامعه في جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين وايضا ينضم الينا من
القاهره محمد كمال عضو المكتب السياسي
لحركه 6 ابريل ومن القاهره ايضا هاشم يحيى
عضو مؤسس في حزب الدستور وابدا مع عبد
الله حموده من لندن سيد عبد الله ما الذي
انجزه سيسي من بحسب وجهه نظرك حتى يعني
استحق ق هذا الدعم الشعبي
والرسمي يعني ال المشير السيسي انجز
الكثير هو ضابط ناجح تدرج في وظائف متعدده
بالقوات المسلحه وله خبره كبيره في
الاداره واثبت في ثوره 30 يونيو 3 يوليو
ان له قدره على اتخاذ القرار في المواقف
الصعبه ومن ثم حظي بهذه الثقه الشعبيه
الكبيره التي تدعوه الان لان يتحمل
مسؤوليه اخرى في مرحله شديده الاهميه من
تاريخ مصر يعني وانا اذا كان لي ان اقول
شيئا فالتقرير الذي قدم به هذا البرنامج
يعني يتسم بالتحيز الشديد وكان هناك نوع
من الغيظ من التاييد الذي يحظى به السيسي
وتركيز على جوانب سلبيه تعتبر خارج
الموضوع لو اردنا مناقشه اين شعرت بذلك اي
جمله اوحت لك بذلك سيد حموده حتى حتى لا
تعمم هكذا وتتهم بدون اي دليل اين شعرت
بذلك في اي جمله من التض اعطيني فرصه وانا
اقوللك يعني الحديث عن انه حاضر هقوللك
يعني اذا كان هناك حديث عن حلم اذا كان
هناك حديث عن تامر اذا كان هناك حديث قل
تامر قلنا حال ما هو تحقق حلمه اين
الانحياز في ذلك هو حل هو قال مع
السدات حلم كل مواطن مصري كل مواطن مصري
له الحق ان يحلم ان يكون رئيسا وا اذا قبل
الشعب ذلك ورشحه وايده الحديث الحديث عن
حلم اي شخص م بذلك بالتحديد عن السيسي هذا
يجعلنا منحين الصيغه التي انا اسف جدا في
البدايه لكن تسمحي لي اقول لك ان الصيغه
التي تحدث بها التقرير تركز على سلبيات
وهناك حاجه الى موضوعيه اذا كان هناك حاجه
لكسب مصداقيه لدى المشاهد و والحصول على
التاييد الذي كانت تحظى به الجذ الجزيره
من قبل ش عفوا اي سانقل اليك مثلا ما
قالته حركه 6 ابريل دعك من تقرير الجزيره
ومعنا اصلا محمد كمال من حركه السادس من
ابريل سيد محمد كمال انتم انتم قلتم انه
هذه الخطوه اعلان رسمي بان سيسي قائد
الانقلاب وقائد الثوره المضاده هذا ما
قالته حركه 6 ابريل يا سيد حموده اذا سيد
سيد محمد كمال لما وصفتم على هذه
الشاكله طيب مساء الخير الاول و بحي ضيوف
حضرتك اهلا في البدايه في البدايه بس
خليني اتكلم عن الموضوعيه اللي بيتكلم بها
استاذنا الكاتب الصحفي في خبر على الشريط
عندكم بيقول ان مؤيدي السيسي يعتزمون
تسيير مسيرات الى ميدان التحرير غدا ميدان
التحرير هو رمز الثوره المصريه جزء من
المصريين يسمح لهم بالاحتفال والرقص في
ميدان التحرير والثوار الذين دخلوا ميدان
التحرير واقاموا الثوره المصريه يحجب عنهم
ميدان التحرير بالرصاص الحي وبكل الوسائل
وكان اخرا في 25 يناير
2014 سيدتي من الذي قال اننا لا لا نخطط
لحسب مصر عفوا ماذا لم
افهم مين اللي قال ان انا مش عايز احكم
مصر عبد الفتاح السيسي مين اللي قال لن
اسمح بان يقال ان المؤسسه العسكريه تحركت
في الثالث من يوليو من اجل ان يتولى
قارتها احد احد قارتها السلطه عبد الفتاح
السي من الذي
سئل عن 3 يوليو ثوره الانقلاب وقال عظيم
انقلاب اذا تحققت بعض الشروط اولها ان
يتولى احد او اهمها ان يتولى احد قاره
الجيش
رئاسه الجمهوريه وهذا قد وضح منذ الامس
طيب امام كل ذلك امام كل ذلك ما هو تصوركم
للمرحله المقبله
اذا تصورنا للمرحله المقبله ان الانتخابات
هي مسرحيه عباسيه هزليه ليس علاقه للثوره
المصريه بها لعده اسباب اولا مؤسسات
الدوله لن تقف على الحياد حيث ان كل
مؤسسات الدوله منذ شهور عديده وهي تلهث
خلف تجييش الشعب خلف مرشح واحد وهو ممثل
المؤسسه العسكريه رقم اين كنا ايام مبارك
نقول عزبه مبارك واولاده والان هناك شبكات
ترتبط
بالمرشح المحتمل عبد الفتاح السيسي اولا
هو عين رئيسا للاركان
و صديقه الصدوق وزيرا للدفاع ثم كل شركات
المصالح المرتبطه بالحزب الوطني
الديمقراطي هي من تعمل لاجله منذ فتره
طويله في النهايه اعلان وزير الدفاع عن
ترشحه لمنصب بئسه وهو مرتدي زي العسكري
يؤكد عدم وقوف المؤسسه العسكريه على
الاحيا طيب وده بياكد شكوكنا في ال اليه
الانتخابيه برمتها وعثر سلبا على العمليه
الديمقراطيه اللي احنا بقالنا سنين طويله
الناظر عشانها ودفع عشانها المصريين كمال
هل هذا اعلان نهايه ثوره يناير وقد كنتم
من
محركها عفوا لم اسمع السؤال هل هذا اعلان
نهايه ثوره يناير وكنتم من ابرز محركها
سيدتي الثورات لا تموت الثورات تمر مراحل
المد والجذر نحن الان في مرحله الجذر ولكن
هناك موجه ثوريه تعصف بكل الظلمه وبكل
القتله في خلال اقل من عام الشعب المصري
يغلي الشعب المصري انا كتبت النهارده وانا
وانا بتجول في القاهره والجيزه في الصباح
مشاهدات المواطن المصري لسه الياس ملكه
المواطن المصري
لسه بيعاني الامرين من الذل شكرا لك
للحصول على لقمه العيش والامن
فبالتالي الانتخابات لم تضيف للمصريين اي
شيء شكرا جزيلا ل شكرا جزيلا لك
وصلت
فكرتك من القاهره محمد كمال عضو المكتب
السياسي لحركه 6 ابريل انتقل الى هاشم
يحيى وضو مؤسس في حزب الدستور من القاهره
ينضم الينا سيد هاشم لم افهم موقف حزب
الدستور المتحدث باسم الحزب قال بالحرف ان
الحزب سيميل لدعم مرشح ياتي من المعسكر
المدني الديمقراطي لانه اقرب لتصوره هل
هذا يعني رفض للسيسي ام خشيه من التعبير
بصراحه عن الرفض
للسيسي يعني حتى الان لن يك لن يكون هناك
موقف محدد سواء لدعم شخصيه موجوده ولكن
الاقرب اننا لن ندعم مرشح اسك انه يختلف
مع الافكار السياسيه التي ينتمي اليها
الحزب الافكار الثوريه التي نؤكد عليها ان
الحكم العسكري ليس متفق مع افكارنا ولا
الحكم الديني فاعتقد ان الفتره القادمه لن
يدعم حزب الدستور اي مرشح وسنعمل على
القواعد مره اخرى القواعد الشعبيه التي
تركناها كثيرا وهي سبب من اسباب ما يحدث
الان شباب الثوره والقوى المدنيه ترقت
الشارع للقوى المغرضه سواء طيب انت تفسر
الماء بالماء لم افهم انتم تدعمون ترشح
سيسي ام
لا حتى الان لا يوجد موقف وكني ا لم ندعم
اي مرشح عكري لما لا لما لا اشرح لي سيد
هاشم خاصه انه لو سمحت لي في اكتوبر
الماضي قبل استقالته البرادعي مؤسس حزب
الدستور كان يعتقد ان السيسي لن يترشح
وكان مؤمنا بذلك وقال الحمد لله السيسي لن
يترشح في احدى تصريحاته هذا يعني ان حزب
الدستور مؤسس حزب الدستور ضد ترشح السيسي
الان حزب الدستور ليس لديه موقف يعني
الموقف الواضح ان اننا لن نرشح اي اي اي
لن ندعم اي مرشح عسكري وهذا واضح كل شباب
الثوره وكل القوى المدنيه الى حد كبير
تنتمي الى الثوره لن تدعم مرشح عسكري ولن
تدعم مرشح ديني ولكن اعتقد في الفتره
القادمه انهم سيتم الحجوب عن ترشيح اي احد
او دعم اي احد من الموجودين لان لا يوجد
شخصيه الان تعبر عن الثوره وعن مطالبها
التي نسعى اليها على طول الخص والثوره
فعلا لن تموت وتستمر وسنعود مره اخرى
للقواعد الشعبيه ل نوعيها نذكرها بشهدائنا
ونذكرها
بالم الاجتما هل توافق ان انقل عنك بان
حزب الدستور لا يؤيد ترشح اسيسي ولن يدعمه
ل لست لست المتحدث الرسمي بحزب الدستور
ولكن هذه وجهه نظر عضو في
الحزب الموقف الرسمي سيعلن قريبا من حزب
الدستور واعتقد ان الموقف الرسمي هو الذي
يجب ان يذاع وليس موقف يمنعه من اخذ موقف
الان ما الذي يؤخركم عن الموقف لم يتم فتح
باب الترشيح حتى الان ولم نعرف من هم
المرشحين سيكون الموقف
عندما كل المرشحين حمدين صباحي حمدين
صباحي يعني اعتقد انها خطوه يعني مبكره
جدا للاعلان عن دعم اي مرشح لسه منتظرين
نشوف ايه اللي هيحصل الايام الجايه هاشم
يحيى عضو مؤسس في حزب الدستور من القاهره
شكرا جزيلا لك انتقل الى ضيفي في اسطنبول
محمد جمال حشمت القيادي في جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين سيد
حشمت ما الذي ستفعلون وعندما تعترف الدول
بالسيسي رئيسا
لمصر بحسب السيناريو القائم يعني بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم يعني نعم انا بس يعني كنت
اود ان يكون النقاش حول هذه القضيه مركزا
حتى لا يخرج بنا احد في تفاصيل لا لزمه
لها هذه القضيه لها من حيث الشكل عشان
نتكلم بكلام واضح بقى نمسك العصايه من
النص خلينا نتكلم بكلام واضح وصريح من حيث
الشكل ومن حيث الموضوع من حيث الشكل في
كلام ومن حيث الموضوع في كلام كتير من حيث
الشكل اولا المظهر الذي ظهر به الفريق
السيسي لابس لبس عسكري قتالي بتاع وحده
قتاليه حتى مش بتاع حضور مجلس اعلى عسكري
وكاتب الجيش المصري وكاتب ع الفتاح السيسي
وبتاع صعقه هو مش بتاع صعقه ح مظهر نفسه
كله مثير
ل لعلامات الاستفهام ايضا الصوت يعني
الصوت لم يكن صوتا عسكريا قويا ولم يكن
صوتا سياسيا محنكا انما كان صوت اقرب الى
الرخامه من من الحنجره وصوت الفنانين
والسهوكه يعني لم يك
حد يتكلم في عالم السياسه من حيث الموضوع
هناك مخاطر عديده تتعرض لها البلاد
الحقيقه بهذا الترشيح اولا اظهر الوجه
الحقيقي لهذا الانقلاب العسكري لانه
باختصار اقصى رئيسه واقصى البرلمان وعطل
الدستور وقتل واصاب واعتقل اكثر من 60 ال
مصري علشان يترشح الى يرشح نفسه الى
الرئاسه ثانيا الترشيح السيسي يضع الجيش
الان في مواجهه الشعب ليه لانه ترشح ببز
ته العسكريه هو لازال وزيرا للدفاع وثم
هناك تفويض من المجلس الاعلى العسكري
بترشيحه لاعلى منصب سياسي في البلد وده
عمل سياسي وبالتالي نحن امام حزب سياسي
عسكري استخدام الجيش لمصالحه الشخصيه يمثل
خطوره على امن مصر الامر الثالث ان هذا
الترشيح بعد فتره تردد طويله الحقيقه فيه
اشكاليات يؤكد ان هناك اشكاليات داخل جبهه
الانقلاب وهي انقسامات معلومه دائمه في كل
الانقلابات العسكريه ونموذج عبد الناصر
لدينا الذي تخلص من كل من منحه الشرعيه
وكل الانقلابات في العالم تخلصت من من
افرادها ا ضيفي على ذلك بقى من حيث
الموضوع القدره الشخصيه للفريق السيسي على
اداره مصر يعني اذا كان ا فعل او قام
بانقلاب عسكري دموي معه سلاح وفشل حتى
الان في هذا الانقلاب اللي يفشل في في عمل
انقلاب مسلح والدنيا كلها ساكته عليه
وبتسقف له وبدعم هينجح في اداره دوله الم
اهلات الشخصيه لا تسمح بذلك بدليل ان مصر
التسع شهور اللي فات الفاعل الرئيسي فيها
هو كان السيسي فماذا حدث لمصر في الناحيه
الاقتصاديه في الناحيه الامنيه في الناحيه
الخارجيه في الناحيه الاجتماعيه هو يمثل
مشكله خطيره في النسيج الاجتماعي تكلم
فيما قبل وقال انا لا اريد ان احدث فتنه
طائفيه او حرب اهليه اوق مظلم كما كان
يدعي هذا وصف وانتقاد لكن سؤالي كان يعني
دعيني اتكلم اعطيتك اعطيتك الفرصه لكن
سؤالي كان هذا الوصف ترددون دائما في
التظاهرات يجري ترديده كل المعارضين
يرددون هذا الكلام لكن الان الخطه تسير
وستكون هنالك شرعيه جديده في مصر ستج
الانتخابات انا
اسالك لا اتكلم في شعارات انا لا اتكلم في
شعارات عشان تقوللي بتتقال في المظاهرات
انا اتكلم في تحليل ينبني عليه سؤالك اللي
بتساليني عليه سؤالي هو ماذا انتم فاعلون
عندما عندما عندما تسير هذه يا فندم نحن
نحن نحن الان نحن الان نحن الان القوى
الثوريه في في التحالف الوطني التحالف
الوطني الثوري المؤيد للشرعيه والقوى
الثوريه الشبابيه في الشارع المصري
الان لديها فرصه لاتخاذ موقف واحنا قلنا
ان هذا الموقف جاري بحثه الان والوقت
مناسب لاتخاذ هذا هذا امر انا لا اتكلم
فيه الان ولكن اتكلم على ان ترشح السيسي
يمثل خطوره حتى على مؤيدين يعني لن لن ي
يف الا جا ليتك بدات اجابتك عن هذه
الخطوره انت انت وصفت لم لم يعني تتقدم في
الاجابه لمرحله سؤال نفسه يعني ما هي
المخاطر وما هي خطتكم البديله على اي حال
ساتوقف مع فاصل قصير نناقش بعده كيف سيؤثر
ترشح السيسي على مسار التحول الديمقراطي
وعلى مستقبل مدنيه الدوله نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش دلالات ترشح المشير عبد الفتاح
السيسي لرئاسه مصر وتداعياته على مستقبل
البلاد سيد حشمت ساواصل معك ان لم احصل
على الاجابه الشافيه لناحيه
انكم ايضا في سؤال اخر في تصريح لوكاله
انباء الاناضول قلتم ان حدثا مهما سيهز
الانقلاب الشهر المقبل هل تبلور شيء من
ملامح هذا الحدث ما وما هو تصوركم
للمستقبل بعد كل الوصف الذي
وصفته انا انا تكلمت في في هذا الامر
تفصيلا و وذكرت بعض من من ملامحه ولكنه
الان لست مخولا بالحديث ع ما سيحدث الفتره
الماضيه من قبل ترشح السيسي انما قضيه
ترشح السيسي الحقيقه هي اللي تحتاج ان
احنا نفهم ان وجوده على راس السلطه في مصر
يمثل او يؤكد لمن كان مخدوعا في الانقلاب
انه انقلابا عسكريا دمويا ان برنامجه الذي
طرحه يعني ايه برنامج ايه اللي بيقول انا
هعمل حمله انتخابيه غير تقليديه ازاي غير
تقليديه وانت تمسل للاراده الشعبيه هي
اللي طالباك وبالتالي يجب ان تكون وسط
الشعب عندما تعلن ترشحك وسط الشعب في عرض
برنامجك ثم دعيني اسال لماذا تاخر ترشحه
لحد ما عمل اللواء بتاع مكافحه الارهاب هل
هذا اللواء مخصوص لحمايه السيسي عندما
يخرج من وزاره الدفاع تع نسال طب احنا
لدينا الان ثلاث سبعات وثلاث تسعات
ضيفي من لندن السيد عبد الله حموده طرح
سؤالا السيد من اسطنبول وايضا اضيف
عليه ان ترتيب البيت العسكري على هذه
الشاكله مساله
صهره الا يعتبر الا يوحي ذلك بهشاشه موقف
السيسي واعتماده فقط على دعم الجيش اكثر
من الانجاز
الشعبي هذا يعني سؤال في غير محله لان
ترتيب امور المؤسسه العسكريه وترتيب
اوضاعها باعتبارها عمود فقري في الحركه
الوطنيه المصريه الان امر مهم جدا لكن
دعيني اسوق ملاحظه مهمه جدا على ما قاله
الدكتور جمال حشم يعني لانه الخطاب يتسم
بالتخبط والتردد وهذا يعكس المازق الذي
تعيشه جماعه الاخوان الان فالدكتور جمال
حشم طرح فكره مبادره للمصالحه هو نفسه
ولكن هذه لم تلقى ردا ولن تلقى ردا في
الوقت الحاضر لان جماعه الاخوان تحاول
زعزعه الامن والنظام والسلام الاهلي في
مصر وتحاول خلق المشاكل ثم تلوم النظام
بها وهي في ظل قيادتها الحاليه لن
يمكن تحصل على مصالحه وان تنضم اسالك عن
السيسي دعني من الاخوان يعني هو يرد عن
السيسي وانت ترد عن الاخوان والمفروض
العكس بينكما سيد حموده يعني سيد حشم
اكتفى بالانتقاد وانت تكتفي
بالانتقاد
نظره للمستقبل منك انا اريد تفسيرا
وتحليلا و يعني حتى نفهم المستقبل الذي
ينتظر
مصر قل لي مثلا عندما يقول لن ادير حمله
انتخابيه تقليديه ماذا يعني بذلك ماذا
يعني بذلك السيسي دعني من الاخوان ماذا
يعني بحمله انتخابيه حمله انتخابيه غير
تقل لا يتم فيها انفاق الاموال دون
طائل تلفزيون الرسمي يا سيد حموده ما
تفسيرك
لخدام هذه هذه هي مرحله هي
يعني ي اسمحي لي اكلم يعني استخدام
التلفزيون الرسمي في هذا السياق هو تعبير
عن تغيير في مؤسسه الدوله وخروج مسؤول
رفيع المستوى هو خصم لاولئك الذين حاولوا
ان يدمروا البلاد وخرج الشعب ضدهم في 30
يونيو
هذه هو هو وزير الدفاع ورئيس اقوى مؤس سه
هي العمود الفقري للحركه الوطنيه المصريه
في الوقت الحاضر هذا امر مهم لكن دعيني
اكلم مستقبل واجيب هذه
النقطه سؤال من 6 ابريل قالوا انه في كان
وعد بميثاق شرف اعلامي وعد بها المشير في
خطاب ثلاثه من يوليو لم تتحقق الان يسخر
الاعلام المشير لم يكن يحكم المشير لم يكن
يحكم المشير كان رئيس المؤسسه عسكريه
وعندما يحكم سيطالب بهذا وسيطرح برنامجا
وسيتم النقاش على اساس هذا البرنامج طيب
سيد حشمت اختم معك لاقول ان السيد حموده
يقول انه ان السيسي لا لا يحكم الان عندما
يحكم يطالب يعني اذا لم يكن يحكم وسخرت
سخر التلفزيون الرسمي له اذا حكم ماذا
سيجري برايك مدنيه الدوله اين ستكون ثوره
يناير اين
ستكون اسمحي لي خارطه الطريق التي اعلنها
الفريق السيسي والتي جاء بموجبها برئيس
للدوله هو الذي وضع تفاصيلها وهو استدعى
السياسيين في مشهد الدكتوره منى مكرم عبيد
اللي استدعوه على وجه السوره عشان يطلعوا
بيان يطلبوا تدخل الجيش قبل الساعه ثه وهو
اللي نظم لمظاهرات 30 يونيو والتي انتهت
يوم 30 يونيو بدون اي طائل اللهم الا
انذار 48 ساعه اذا هو الفاعل الرئيسي هذه
الملفات التي تدار في البلد لا يستطيع احد
ان يتخذ فيها هذه هي منظومه مبارك بالضبط
لا احد يملك قرار الا بالعوده الى الجهات
الامنيه مره ثانيه ففكر ان هو بقى خلينا
نشوف هيعمل ايه يعني هندي لنفسنا فرصه
ثانيه لمؤسسه عسكريه بعد 60 سنه خراب احنا
احنا بدانا في الخمسينات مع مع مع
52 اليابان بدات معانا والهند بدات معانا
والمانيا بدات معانا شوفوا هم فين واحنا
فين الان نديهم فرصه ايه اذا كان
المعارضين كلهم في السجون يا اما قتله يا
اما مصابين يا اما في السجون واللي في
الشارع بينضربوا متهمون راي الاخر
مقفول انتم انتم نفسكم متهمون بانكم اعدتم
انتاج الدوله الامنيه بسبب
بسبب حقبه حكم
الاخوان الدوله الامنيه اللي عدناها ازاي
اذا كان رئيس وزير الداخليه كان لا ياخذ
قراراته من الرئيس وبيقول لك اعدت الامن
الوطني دون ان يعلم الرئيس وز بقول
المخابرات التقارير خطا جعلتم الناس تتوحد
حول حول مسؤول اخر حتى ولو كان
عسكري
يعني هذا انقلاب عسكري هذا انقلاب وهذه
خيانه للشرعيه الشرعيه الت تمثل اراده
الشعب المصري هؤلاء الذين خانوا الشرعيه
لا يحتمل ابدا ان يهتموا بمص شكرا لك
انتهى الوقت من اسطنبول محمد جمال حشمه
القيادي في جماعه الاخوان المسلمين واشكر
الكاتب الصحفي عبد الله حموده حدثنا من
لندن بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده في مراء خبر
جديد
[موسيقى]
ا